David Spade
the actor we saw him on Good Morning
America looking he looked good
Sandler had the same t-shirt on he's had
on for two weeks
spade joins us him what is up with that
with Sandler and that green shirt that
was one of the funniest one of the good
it's a green v-neck t-shirt and
basketball shorts and this shirt has a
big rip in it I think it's were regular
crummy that's enough but yet they're all
ripping it too but does he have a
certain style so he has to wear that
stuff I mean he has no style but does he
have to continue to do that it's it's a
comfort and then B they usually are
playing basketball after whatever we do
so it's like do I need to change if they
didn't want America or come we just go
straight to basketball so that and I
look weird cuz I dress okay this morning
doesn't I felt stupid
you look like never a bit beyond you
look like a French waiter today I don't
know I can't we we did a show in
Brooklyn last night we all got home at
1:30 and then I could get up at 6:00
you know think about good merit morning
Americas we get there an hour early I'm
rushing and dying in them and then they
go okay you're almost done we get there
they go now you wave the camera and then
it's another 45 cold it to the the
Dennett's have a dilemma here they were
sent a form to see if they wanted to
join the Screen Actors Guild and okay
but it cost three grand for each of them
to join is it worth them in and they're
probably never gonna be in another movie
again so would it be worth getting a
Screen Actors Guild card I know you're
in the sweater guild right I'm funny
though I'm talking about we get to talk
about I jumped in on it I have a
half-sister on right now if you're
talking what they kind of bit from like
about like your chest up so you mean
will you just
the damn question alright well I'm
trying to help you but whatever I I
don't think it's worth it because
they're uncatchable that's what my first
agent told me and I don't know if
they're gonna get if they're gonna
pursue it this hard it's a lot of money
wait wait wait you were told you were
uncountable by your first agent know
what the first agent that he did say two
things one my first headshot I was
happily like a super fruity picture but
I was like in a turtleneck but they go
what's with these crow's feet and I
don't want meanwhile I look 14 you know
I'd watch it because you're only gonna
be able to play high school after that
nothing I don't want so from then on I
got so psycho about I didn't make facial
expressions for two years because they
get on you about that that's why this
town grows you know and I had one age
ago
you're the best actor out there you have
to sign with me and you're gonna have
the best career and then I was torn
between two and I picked the other one
and I called him which this is why I
always text now because I called you the
right thing and did in person and ago
you just made the biggest mistake of
your life one he goes you're gonna have
a horrible career now I gotta know did
you heal it
you know half right you brought this up
on Good Morning America that you were
auditioning for in living color and you
were up you're up against Jim Carrey so
they were they were hired they are
hiring either you or Jim Carrey on in
living color what do you remember about
that final addition I will say all I
remember is a I'm not as good as Jim
Carrey and I didn't know it was against
him if I did I would have skipped it but
it was just I go in so many auditions
back then you just go you got one in the
valley and then you got one for you know
for wax are you gonna wear a suit and
you gotta wear a shirt so you're doing
this all day you don't even know what
your audition for and let me tell her I
started getting called back she do
improv and I don't know how it surviving
I'm not a great improv er
but they did need a white guy and I was
getting me out of the wire
and here's all I remember I had a
two-week juicy gig in Hawaii and the
final callback was the second day of the
two weeks and I called and said can I
come late and they go no if we're just
gonna cancel your whole two weeks and I
go for the audition I'm never gonna get
and I stayed and did it and did not get
it and founded it was Jim Carrey I'm
like oh so you had a stand-up gig in
Hawaii yeah for two weeks yeah but it's
a better story that you went toe-to-toe
with Jim Carrey and you barely lost down
to it I didn't look I feel like it was a
landslide I wasn't I even wasn't any
good I was knowing I'm like I'm not good
for this I don't do characters and the
other in one who's that like nothing
keeps going and then he was so perfect
for it I go why did you waste all of our
time on he's so Dave he had 45
characters I had Michael j5
hey Sarge what are we doing this so you
had one character for in living color
only so many sketches you can use
Michael J Fox on in living color right
now David's made the new movies that do
over available on Netflix beginning
tomorrow
I thought you ain't how about this you
know I got a question for you first of
all
Oh Johnny Manziel is just in my hair
elevator oh that's a sports story right
we're late where are you in the New York
Johnny manziel's there yeah he's in my
elevator you said they had a big family
Hannah darling do you know him honey I
don't know I just got up in the night I
said oh thanks man I look back on one's
clothing I'm like Johnny would well he
goes it's Johnny vodka
do you is not official yet but I'm
working on the tree okay great Johnny
vodka good luck with that
alright do you have a question for me no
I was gonna say I forgot you in the
do-over and you were great and I you had
Samantha sign she's at the premiere and
I was wondering if she thought it was
funny too because she said she was going
on your show yeah she she has a
boyfriend by the way yeah started yes
works at happy Madison ah but she was
friendly listen you were great in it you
were really funny and I think I saw an
earlier time I think they added more of
your jokes in the second cut oh they did
yeah you did great
I thought Paula Patton looks spectacular
oh my god yes she is so stunning in
person and so great on screen I need to
see her no Denzel Washington movies now
listen she took a huge step down with me
she's pulled a hamstring but he's very
very pretty and very sweet and I had no
business that's what you do when you do
like a real movie just like a real movie
yes I got action comedy and there's and
then you can get a great cast like that
cuz it's a cooler when we and I loved it
she was great there's a lot of a lot of
good people on it did you uh did you
think you had a shot with her not even
in the script list as I do yeah you have
to you have to make out with her no she
has to make out with you oh yeah it's
horrifying
believe me I felt bad when I told her
the whole time and she knew it and she
was like going along with it but I know
on her phone your agent feverishly going
funny Sandler puts his off you're taller
than me like everybody and she is like
surly and gorgeous and sailors wife's in
the movie what if you had that make out
with Sandler's wife Wow good question I
don't think he would let that happen I
don't think he'd let anyone because she
gets it she has a really cute funny part
and she's very cute in it with another
girl
that's the threesome and how about it
was the other girl of course oh I know
that was that was a crazy seat I've used
to seeing some crazy things with Sandler
stuff that that's probably one of the
top five craziest cringe-worthy scenes
I've ever seen in a Sandler movie yeah
don't don't give it away I know I'm glad
you're not giving it away that's that
one I was like oh boy I knew it was
coming and it was worse than I thought
where is the Comedy Tour next up we go
to bash turn tomorrow no tonight we did
last night was fun here in Brooklyn and
Chris Rock came in what's up
so we introduced instead of when I got
off instead of introducing Sandler they
go
this next guy was in The Longest Yard
shouting lies all of the ones Chris
rocks into and then and then he went up
consider bout him and the crowd whoo
yeah and then he went on in and out but
tonight's boss and then Mohegan Sun in
Connecticut I wish we kept doing this
this has been so fun
how good is Rock though when he's doing
stand-up he was saying today guys I'm
not as good as you guys anymore I was
like okay you guys are but he came out
there and he was talking about how to
dirty but he was talking about I don't
know yeah yeah we buddy with you yeah
you can't buy that it's really good he's
always really funny and he loved it he
was like you know what I forget it's so
fun to go out there and I got rock just
you know come with us for a while or
don't do it and in this practice again
because he's done in problems we've had
dinner and he does want to know too then
we go over there watch somebody and then
he goes maybe yeah you want let's book
one so we both need 15 minutes and uh I
go off and they're like oh that was
pretty good oh my god he's David
Chappelle malama the
he comes out tomorrow on Netflix it's
called the do-over I thought you were
great in the movie I really did where
did you see it we would come here yeah I
didn't even see you they shuffled us
down the red carpet yeah it's almost
like the other party yes yeah I wasn't
where I think the carpet was a little
different shade of red where we were it
was like a conveyor belt they were
trying to get us out of there as quickly
as possible you know she'd join sag is a
sandless kids in the team they were
funny yeah I'm surprised they don't have
a sag card already but they were they
were great I have fun on the tour and
tell Sandman we said hello and thanks
again David and thanks for having me on
guys I really appreciate it talk to you
later Bob that's David Spade he likes to
say buh-bye the do-over available on
Netflix beginning tomorrow the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience